hi I'm Nick Gillespie with reason TV and
we're at Freedom Fest in Las Vegas and
today we're talking with brian doherty
senior editor of reason and the author
of ron paul's revolution what happens
next for ron paul between now and the
convention paul failed in nebraska to
win that magic fifth state that by
republican party rules would have
guaranteed him a prime-time speaking
slot which was a big blow however his
his fans are unstoppable and if you're
following talking them and following on
the Internet they're just like onward to
Tampa there will be hundreds of them on
the convention floor they're going to
continue to attempt to influence the
platform which is an iffy proposition in
my mind because I think in the modern
era most people have no idea what the
platform even says but it's something
they're trying to do and to make sure
that their respected on the floor and
there'll be more hundreds of Ron Paul
fans in the streets of Tampa there's
three different Ron Paul festivals
probably going to be happened there one
the Ron Paul approved one where the man
himself will be and to others for his
rowdy or fans what they need to do is
prove to the Republican Party that they
are not just a radical fringe that can
be completely ignored like happened in
2008 but that they are the loyal
opposition in a sense that they are the
other big wing of the party what has Ron
Paul's effect been on Republican Party
politics and do you think not the
platform per se but are they going to
you know has Ron Paul pulled the party
on mass as it heads into the convention
and into election 2012 towards a more
libertarian position on one issue he has
unequivocally which is his pet issue of
monetary policy and anti fed a jeté shin
an issue that had no traction whatsoever
until five years ago and now he can get
every Republican in the house and plenty
of Democrats to vote for audit the Fed
bills I'm not something that probably
will define the Republican Party moving
forward on fiscal policies certainly
Republicans continue to talk like Ron
Paul but you know when Romney was asked
about the trillion-dollar in one year a
spending cut that Ron Paul's proposed he
sort of openly mocked it and in this
kind of Keynesian analysis said oh the
economy would tank if the government
stopped spending a trillion dollars a
year so there's a lot you know a lot of
room to grow certainly for the Paul
people and I think this is not the year
the establishment gets it
Romney gets it enough that he is not
being openly hostile to Paul and I think
if Santorum or Gingrich were leaders
they wouldn't be that smart they'd be
kicking Paul in the face being Romney
alienates Ron Paul fans enough he
doesn't want to needlessly alienate them
more but I don't think that he's taking
them seriously enough that say the VP
candidate will be a Rand Paul or anyone
Paul people would like this is the very
beginning of the crest of the wave that
I do think will be more powerful in the
party for 8-12 talk about that a little
bit who are the people I mean clearly
the Ron Paul fans outside of the outside
of the party machinery you know they're
there and they're going to be growing
and sprouting all over in the party who
are the people you know down the road in
two years and four years and six years
that you think will be carrying the Ron
Paul mantle as the congressman retires
from public office the two most
prominent ones are of course in the
Senate his son r and who is playing a
very delicate balancing act trying to
keep the Ron Paul base while also trying
to not alienate your sort of red meat
talk radio Republicans the way his
father does think he's been successful
in doing that I think he has uh he
definitely angered the Ron Paul hardcore
with his Romney endorsement I think he
was probably smart actually to get it
out of the way so early I misunderstood
that strategically at first I didn't get
why he did it so quick but I think he
did it just to get it as far behind him
as possible and then he started doing a
lot of things to win them back over and
I think he probably will I'm in the
house of course we're hoping that Justin
a mash can keep his seat he was
redistricted so he has to fight but he
is almost more Ron Paul than Ron Paul in
some ways if he keeps a seat he'll be
the the Ron Paul moving forward and I
don't think 2012 is going to be the year
that a lot of new Ron polish Republicans
win but a lot of them are running and
it's just something you have to keep
building momentum and hopefully in 2014
we will see some more results well brian
doherty author of ron paul's revolution
and senior editor reason thanks for
talking to us for reason TV I'm Nicholas
week